[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER HEIDEN:
Hello, everybody.
Last time, I introduced
the idea of the TCA cycle,
tricarboxylic acid cycle.
Also known as the citric acid
cycle, because citric acid
is a tricarboxylic acid,
as you'll see later today.
Also known as the
Krebs cycle, named
after Hans Krebs,
who discovered it
in the early part
of the last century.
The TCA cycle is the
series of reactions
that occurs in the
mitochondrial matrix
and it allows the complete
oxidation of two carbon
units, derived from many things,
including pyruvate, derived
from glucose and glycolysis and
enables the complete oxidation
of that carbon to CO2.
Now, it's a cycle
because those two carbon
units from pyruvate or other
sources enter the cycle,
combine with 4-carbon
oxaloacetate,
and combine to make
6-carbon citrate.
Hence the citric
acid cycle, or TCA
cycle, that is then oxidized
back to 4 carbon units,
forming a cycle
that allows cells
to release lots of energy.
Complete oxygen
enables, ultimately,
complete oxidation
of glucose to CO2.
We've talked many times
how this releases energy.
And it also generates
lots of intermediates
for the cell that can be
used to make other stuff.
Last time, I alluded to the
fact that citrate can be
used, say, to make fatty acids.
Today, what I want to
do is I want to dive
into the details of how
this TCA cycle occurs
and the consequences
of the way it works,
and how that affects other
aspects of metabolism.
You'll see that it
actually affects
the ability of
different organisms,
whether or not they
can make things
from intermediates
in this cycle,
because of how the cycle works.
Now, to start.
Of course, if we're going
to start from pyruvate.
Pyruvate, of course,
has three carbons.
And so if we're going to
generate a two-carbon acetate
group, we have to lose CO2.
And as I described a
couple lectures ago,
acetate is also
the thing that we
can derive from
metabolism of ethanol,
showing us two things--
metabolized glucose to
pyruvate or ethanol itself--
can both be turned into acetate.
But really, the donor is
this molecule, acetyl-CoA.
Which is basically also a
carboxylic acid, but rather
than being a carboxylic
acid, instead makes this
a thioester bond, which
activates this carbon
as a leaving group, such that it
can combine with oxaloacetate,
which you'll remember
from gluconeogenesis,
releasing that S-CoA molecule
to generate six-carbon citric.
So, this is citric.
You can see that we've made
a bond from this carbon
on the acetate, losing this
S-CoA group to this carbon
oxaloacetate to make this
six-carbon citrate molecule,
which is a one, two, three--
three-carboxylic acid,
or tricarboxylic acid.
Hence the name
citric acid cycle,
tricarboxylic acid cycle.
Now, these six
carbons can then--
or this six-carbon
citrate molecule
can then be oxidized, generating
two CO2 molecules that
are released, and
ultimately reforming
oxaloacetate that can pick up
another two-carbon acetyl-CoA
to generate another citrate,
and around and around the cycle
goes, allowing in
the end the net entry
of two carbons,
effectively from acetate,
and release of two
carbons as CO2.
Now, as I alluded to, this
can come from pyruvate.
It can come from
acetate itself, vinegar.
It can come from alcohol.
It turns out that when
you break down fat,
you also break it
into two carbon units.
And so this cycle becomes
very useful for cells,
because it allows the oxidation
of many different molecules
to completely turn
that carbon into CO2.
Now, if we're going to
do this from glucose,
however, you'll remember that
pyruvate has three carbons.
And so if we're going
to turn pyruvate
into acetate, or acetyl-CoA, we
have to lose a carbon of CO2.
We have to lose
this carbon as CO2.
Now, we saw this before,
that we can do this via--
this is exactly how
we generated ethanol
when we did fermentation
of pyruvate to ethanol,
but that molecule
didn't generate acetate,
It generated acetaldehyde.
The difference, of course, being
whether or not this carbon gets
oxidized in the case
of acetate to the acid,
or in acetaldehyde in
ethanol metabolism,
where it remains an aldehyde.
Now obviously, you can
make ethanol and then
turn that ethanol into acetate.
And that's a pathway that I
guess certainly would work.
However, that's not the way
it happens in most organisms.
Most organisms actually
directly produce
acetate, or more correctly,
acetyl-CoA from pyruvate.
So let's take a look
at that reaction.
So here once again is pyruvate.
And if we turn
that pyruvate into
this two-carbon
acetyl-CoA, let's
look here what has to happen.
Well, the first
thing is that we have
to decarboxylate this molecule.
And so that generates a CO2.
We have to lose that one carbon.
Also, as I pointed
out, if we do this
as if we did it in
ethanol metabolism,
we'd be left with an aldehyde.
But this is an acid, and so this
carbon also has to be oxidized.
We know how to do that.
We can donate those electrons
to something like NAD,
so the NAD is reduced to NADH.
And we had to add this
S-CoA molecule, which
I'll come to in a minute.
And so each of
these steps ends up
making a fairly
complicated reaction.
Obviously, several co-factors
are going to be involved.
You should be able to guess
that just by looking at it.
Obviously, I already
drew up there NAD.
If we're going to
decarboxylate, remember
this is a alpha
carboxylic, an alpha
ketoacid-- the ketone group is
alpha to the carboxylic acid.
And so if we're doing
alpha decarboxylation,
as you might guess,
we need a co-factor.
That co-factor, as
I told you before,
is the co-factor factor
thiamine pyrophosphate.
And finally, there's
this S-CoA group.
We need to describe
what that is.
However, before delving
into those, and there's
actually a couple other factors
that are needed as well,
I want to mention
one other issue
about this reaction, in
that this reaction happens
in the mitochondria,
because that's also
where the TCA cycle happens.
So, recall that if we divide
the cell into two compartments
like an eukaryotic cell,
here we have the cytosol
and the mitochondria
in a eukaryotic cell.
As we've already talked about,
having different compartments
helps facilitate different
metabolic reactions,
because you can have different
conditions in the two
compartments.
And so as we said, glycolysis
occurs in the cytosol.
Glucose to pyruvate.
And last time I
mentioned, the TCA cycle
occurs in the mitochondria.
And so that means if we're
going to fully oxidize
the pyruvate carbon
to CO2 using the TCA
cycle in the mitochondria,
that pyruvate
has to get from the cytosol to
the mitochondria, or at least
carbons from the pyruvate
have to get there.
It turns out, you'll
see in a minute,
acetyl-CoA is a
very large group.
And so pyruvate
itself is transported
into the mitochondria.
And that's where
the reaction occurs
to turn it into acetyl-CoA that
can then enter the TCA cycle
and oxidize.
However, what this means is
that a transporter is actually
needed to get this across
the mitochondrial membranes
and into the matrix of the
mitochondria where the TCA
cycle happens.
And I like to mention
this because it turns out
the pyruvate carrier--
that is, the
transporter-- the way
that it actually gets that
pyruvate from the cytosol
into the mitochondria
actually was
an unknown thing
about metabolism
until 2012, so
not that long ago.
Sometimes one can be
left with the feeling,
listening to these metabolism
classes or reading a textbook,
that everything about metabolism
has been known forever,
but it's actually not true.
Here's a very key, central
part of the pathway that
was actually just
discovered, at least
at the time of this lecture,
less than 10 years ago.
It also illustrates that not
all metabolism is completely
understood.
Now, let's get back to this
reaction, how you turn pyruvate
into acetyl-CoA.
And I want to go through
now and point out
that several
co-factors are needed.
And so I already mentioned
one of them, S-CoA,
which is shorthand
for coenzyme A. So,
I need to tell you what that is.
You hopefully are already
familiar with TPP plus,
thiamine pyrophosphate.
We talked about
that when we talked
about how you do alpha
decarboxylation to generate
ethanol from pyruvate,
also used here
for the alpha
decarboxylation reaction.
Redox reaction
happens, and so we
needed NAD plus to get
converted into NADH.
We talked a lot about how that
serves as an electron carrier,
but it turns out that there's
two additional electron
carriers that are
involved in this reaction.
One of them is called
FAD and the other one
is called lipoic acid.
Now you might say,
why do we need
all these electron carriers?
Well, these are just
different molecules
that can carry two
electrons, similar to NADH.
And effectively, what these can
do by having multiple electron
carriers--
one can build chains of
oxidation and reduction
reactions.
And it turns out these chains
of oxidation reduction reactions
really become central to
energy transfers in biology,
because building
these chains allows
more easy stepwise
release of energy
as one moves across these
oxidation reduction reactions.
Which remember, as I
alluded to earlier, really
are at the core of bioenergetics
and a lot of what allows energy
release from these pathways.
What I mean by this
will be more explicit
as we go through what some of
these co-factors look like.
So, I'm not going to draw TPP
plus or NAD again, but let's
define what some of these
other cofactors look like.
So, let's start with coenzyme
A. So, coenzyme A, it turns out,
is useful.
It's actually involved in
lots of acylation reactions.
What's an acylation reaction?
Well, that's basically if you're
making a carbon-carbon bond
by adding a molecule of greater
than one carbon, so two carbons
or greater, to something else.
That's an acylation
reaction, as we
did with adding the two-carbon
acetate to oxaloacetate
to make citrate.
And you'll actually see
coenzyme A will come up
in this in many, many
lectures throughout the rest
of the course.
Why this becomes useful
is because it activates
this basically carbon to
the left of, in this case,
the ketone.
Because, by having
that thioester there,
ends up activating that carbon
and allows it to carry out
these acylation reactions.
Coenzyme A itself is
derived from a vitamin
called pantothenic acid.
And as a vitamin,
this is something
that you have to
get from the diet.
Now, when we
abbreviate coenzyme A,
which is often
abbreviated S-CoA,
you get the sense that it's
this little tiny molecule
that's just stuck on sulfur--
stuck on to the end to
make this thioester bond.
But it turns out coenzyme A is
actually a giant molecule, one
of the reasons why you
actually synthesize acetyl-CoA
in the mitochondria,
because it's
hard to transport
this giant molecule.
And so this is what
pantothenic acid looks like.
So, if I put an acid group here
and a hydroxyl group there,
that would be pantothenic
acid, the thing
that's in your cereal, on
the side of your cereal box.
Then there's these
additional pieces.
This is the active
end of the molecule,
that's that sulfur
from the S-CoA,
and then this side of the
molecule is esterified to two
phosphates, which
are esterified to--
I'm not going to
draw it out, but this
would have an adenine base
and a phosphate there.
So basically, this is
ADP, with a phosphate
added to the 3 prime
position of the ADP molecule,
added to pantothenic acid,
added to this short chain
with the sulfur on the end.
And this whole molecule
together is coenzyme A.
And so when we say
acetyl-CoA, it's
this giant molecule,
S-thioester to the carbonyl,
the acid on acetate, to CH3.
And so that would be,
basically, acetyl-CoA.
And so one convenient
thing about this
is it's much easier than
drawing that big molecule,
but it is a little bit
misleading in terms
of its size.
So, that's coenzyme A.
Next one I want to
talk about is FAD
which stands for flavin
adenine dinucleotide.
So, flavin adenine dinucleotide
is an electron carrier,
just like NAD plus.
And it's derived from
the vitamin riboflavin,
also referred to as vitamin B2.
Another thing from the side of
your cereal box, and basically
looks like this.
So, like NAD, it's
a dinucleotide.
And so here's ADP, just
like we do for CoA, or just
like one end of NAD.
One difference is that the
other nucleotide down here
actually isn't
technically a sugar.
It's ribitol instead of ribose.
What does that mean?
It doesn't have an aldehyde.
Instead, it is just
a five-carbon chain
where all of the
carbons are alcohols.
And so since
there's no aldehyde,
it doesn't form a ring.
And the base on this
end, as a nicotinamide,
is this flavin group,
which looks like this.
And so this is FAD, which
is in the oxidized form.
Turns out, in the
oxidized form, FAD
is yellow, hence riboflavin--
"flavin", yellow.
And the reason it's
yellow-- you see
there's a conjugated double
bond here across this part.
It turns out this is the
active part of the molecule,
and it works as follows.
And so if you have
a hydride ion,
remember the way we can
transfer two electrons.
Can transfer the two
electrons that way,
and that allows it to generate.
And I'll just draw
the middle, here.
Active part of the molecule.
So, that would be
these two nitrogens.
We've added two electrons to it.
And so this is
abbreviated FADH2,
or the reduced form of FAD.
And it is colorless,
because now you no longer
have that conjugated double
bond system, loses its color.
And so you can follow whether
FAD is oxidized or reduced
by just looking at color change.
So, that's FAD.
It's an electron carrier,
carries electrons
by a hydride transfer,
very similarly
to what we described
for NAD, but obviously
a different molecule.
And the last molecule,
the last co-factor
that we need for this
reaction, is lipoic acid.
Which, unlike most
things in metabolism,
doesn't have an abbreviation
and also functions
as an electron carrier.
And so lipoic acid
looks like this.
So, that is lipoic acid.
This is in the oxidized form.
And so where it's
oxidized is here
at this sulfur-sulfur bond.
So, you can think of this as
the same as a disulfide bond
that you learned about from
Professor Yaffe in proteins.
And so this is the oxidized
form of the disulfide bond.
If I take this hydride, transfer
two electrons across that bond,
then it goes to-- and I'll
just draw here the active end.
Then we go here to the
reduced form of lipoic acid,
and there's no
abbreviation for oxidized
or reduced lipoic acid.
It's just lipoic acid,
oxidized lipoic acid, reduced.
And how they're
oxidized and reduced
is basically very similar
to the disulfide bonds
that you saw in proteins being
oxidized, disulfide bond being
oxidized, or it can be reduced
to not be a disulfide bond.
Now, it turns out that these
cofactors, our TPP, FAD,
and lipoic acid, are
all stably associated
with different subunits
of a multi-protein complex
that assembles to catalyze that
reaction to convert pyruvate
to acetyl-CoA.
The enzyme or
enzyme complex that
carries this out is
referred to as PDH,
sometimes abbreviated
PDC, which stands
for the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex.
So, pyruvate dehydrogenase, PDH,
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex,
PDC.
This complex is basically
three different polypeptides
that come together
to form a complex
and catalyze that reaction.
Now, where this complex sits--
so, this is the mitochondria.
This is the matrix.
That's where this pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction occurs.
That's where the
TCA cycle occurs.
And this PDH
complex is basically
sitting here at the
membrane on the matrix side
of the membrane.
Now, the three
different polypeptides
that come together
to form this complex
are creatively named
E1, E2, and E3, four.
Enzyme one, two, and three.
And each of these,
as I alluded to,
is associated with a
different co-factor.
And so E1 is associated
with thymine pyrophosphate.
E2 is associated
with lipoic acid.
And E3 is associated with FAD.
Now, let's go
through the mechanism
for how this pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction works.
So remember, this is the
active part of TBP plus.
It is bound in the
active site of E1.
And it reacts with pyruvate to
catalyze alpha decarboxylation,
just like we described
for conversion of pyruvate
to alcohol.
So, you're going to see
exactly the same mechanism
that we drew before.
So, that decarboxylates
the alpha-keto acid,
just like we saw to
generate acetaldehyde.
The difference is rather
than resolve this such
that this carbon has
the same oxidation state
and make acetaldehyde, instead
the next step of this reaction
is going to be oxidized
by reducing lipoic acid.
So, the active
part of lipoic acid
that is in the active
site of the E2 subunit.
So this will now regenerate
E1, but what we're left with,
then, is this.
Now, this intermediate
bound to E2.
Here's where coenzyme
A can come in, which
will then generate acetyl-CoA.
But now we are left with
E2 in the reduced state,
rather than being in
the oxidized state.
So E2 has to be re-oxidized
in order for this complex
to carry out the next
catalytic cycle, and the way
that works is as follows.
So you have FAD bound on E3.
And so you have a hydride
ion from the oxidation of E3
that can be transferred to FAD.
That will generate FAD from the
oxidized to the reduced form.
So re-oxidize lipoic acid
on E2, reduce FAD to FADH2,
and then that FADH2
can be re-oxidized back
to FAD via transferring
those electrons to NAD
plus to generate NADH.
So in this case, FADH2
re-oxidized the FAD, NAD
plus reduced to NADH.
And so, effectively,
what this happens
is that enzyme E1
and E2 cooperate
to call what's referred to as
oxidative alpha decarboxylation
of pyruvate, while
adding -CoA, so that's
where you get acetyl-CoA, with
reduction of lipoic acid in E2,
and then E3 re-oxidizes
the lipoic acid in E2
while generating NADH.
This NADH, once it's
generated, of course
those electrons have
to go somewhere,
so they, like in glycolysis--
it also needs to regenerate
to NAD at some point.
This is ultimately the
electrons that end up on oxygen,
and it's really this series
of electron transfers,
with oxygen being a good
electron acceptor, that
ultimately allows controlled
energy release during carbon
oxidation.
And cells, you'll see, can
use that to make ATP or do
other kinds of work.
So, the net reaction
and/or another way
to draw the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction
would be as follows, and that's
taking pyruvate to acetyl-CoA.
And so we're going to take
coenzyme A and release CO2.
This is done by TPP
plus, as part of E1.
That involves converting
the lipoic acid in E2
from the oxidized to
the reduced state.
That lipoic acid then
has to be re-oxidized.
If something's
oxidized, something else
has to be reduced.
That's FAD on E3,
which also then cycles
between the oxidized
and reduce state.
And ultimately, those
electrons ended up
being transferred to NAD
plus to generate NADH.
And so the PDH complex
is basically a chain
of electron transfer reactions.
And it's the first example of
a chain of electron transfer
reactions.
We're going to see that there
is the electron transport
chain in the mitochondria,
effectively does
the same thing.
And by coupling oxidation
and reduction reactions
across chains of molecules like
this, effectively as a preview,
allows the stepwise energy
release of these oxidation
reactions to occur.
So remember, if we burn glucose,
completely oxidize it in one
step, where those electrons
are directly transferred
to oxygen in combustion.
Lots of energy released,
but all in one step.
By doing these stepwise
electron transfers,
we can then basically break
up that energy release
in a way that can be
captured by cells to do work.
Here, the way
energy is captured,
it's not so obvious in this
electron transport reaction.
But effectively,
you're using oxidation
of the ketone on pyruvate, with
decarboxylation to the acid
to generate, rather than just
the acid, a thioester bond.
And that's that thioester bond--
as well as NADH, that's
energy as well-- but it's
really that thioester bond that
then can be recaptured later
to drive synthesis of
citrate in the TCA cycle.
Now, next what I want to do is
I want to discuss the TCA cycle
reactions.
Now that you see how you
can get acetyl-CoA, at least
from pyruvate, I want to
discuss how you can now
use that acetyl-CoA and
oxidize it back to combine it
with oxaloacetate,
and oxidize it back
to make citrate, and then
oxidize it back to oxaloacetate
to run the TCA cycle.
OK, great.
So, the first reaction
of the TCA cycle.
Here's acetyl-CoA.
It will combine
with oxaloacetate.
This reaction is catalyzed by an
enzyme called citrate synthase,
and generates the six-carbon
tricarboxylic acid citrate.
So, how does this reaction work?
Here's drawing acetyl-CoA
in a slightly different way.
If I redraw this
as the enol, this
will generate citrate via,
effectively, that mechanism.
Next, citrate is
converted by adding water
across this carbon-carbon,
or by removing water
across this carbon-carbon
bond, to generate
this intermediate
called cis-aconitate.
So this intermediate is
so all I did was
dehydrate across that bond
so there's a double bond there.
And then if I re-add
water across that bond,
I generate this molecule
called isocitrate.
So effectively, to convert
citrate to isocitrate,
I'm moving the hydroxyl
group from that carbon
to this carbon.
To do that, I basically
dehydrate, make a double bond,
remove water, re-add
water across that bond
in the opposite direction
to generate this molecule,
isocitrate.
This reaction is carried out
by an enzyme called aconitase,
and converts citrate
to isocitrate.
I think it's a little
easier to see this reaction
if I draw it a
slightly different way.
So, this here is
just drawing citrate
by just slightly rotating the
molecule to look like that.
And so I'm basically
removing water here.
And then I'm now just
adding water back
in the opposite orientation
to generate isocitrate.
Now, you'll notice
when I drew this--
if you look at citrate, this
is actually a symmetrical
molecule, so the top half and
the bottom half of citrate
are identical.
And so what's interesting
about nature is
that it treats these carbons--
the green carbons that
came from acetyl-CoA--
different from the side
of the molecule that
comes from oxaloacetate.
And effectively, nature always
moves the hydroxyl group
to this carbon that
came from oxaloacetate,
and never moves
it to this carbon
that came from acetyl-CoA.
This is an example
where enzymes--
nature treats a symmetrical
molecule like citrate
in an asymmetrical way.
And this has consequences for
how carbon is actually traced
through the entire TCA cycle.
Because even though you
might think things could get
scrambled at citrate,
they never do.
Meaning an isocitrate-- it's
always these green carbons
that came from acetyl-CoA.
You never get
those green carbons
on the other side of isocitrate.
And so when we go
through the TCA cycle,
I'll keep these carbons
green until the point where
you can no longer distinguish
which carbon came from
came from which reaction.
The next reaction is
we're going to oxidize
this carbon of isocitrate.
So if we're going to
oxidize that carbon,
those electrons have
to go somewhere.
And so if we oxidize
the carbon, we
can use NAD plus as an electron
acceptor, reduce it to NADH.
That generates
this intermediate.
So hopefully this is clear
to everybody at this point,
but just in case.
So, this carbon
here and isocitrate.
If I oxidize that
alcohol to the ketone,
now I generate a hydride ion.
Those two electrons and the
hydrogen can go to NAD plus
and reduce it to NADH.
That generates
this intermediate.
It's called oxalosuccinate.
Which then, if you
notice, the oxalosuccinate
is now a beta keto acid.
So alpha, beta.
The acid group is
beta to the ketone,
so it's a beta keto acid.
Remember, beta
decarboxylation is favorable,
and so I can lose that CO2.
And what I'm left with
is this molecule, which
is called alpha keto glutarate.
So this whole reaction
here, the oxidation
of the alcohol to
the ketone, followed
by beta decarboxylation
of oxalosuccinate
to alpha ketoglutarate,
is carried out
by an enzyme called
isocitrate dehydrogenase.
And of course,
just to remind you,
here's that beta keto
acid in oxalosuccinate.
And so that can decarboxylate,
leading this enol.
Which can, of course, rearrange
back to the ketone that we see,
an alpha ketoglutarate.
Now, if you look at
alpha ketoglutarate,
you'll notice that-- and
I will redraw over here.
So, this here is just me
redrawing alpha ketoglutarate,
which is often
abbreviated alpha kG.
Just drew it as a straight line.
Now, if you'll notice,
alpha keto glutarate
is a alpha ketoacid.
And so here the acid group
is alpha to the ketone.
So, an alpha keto acid.
It's effectively
just like pyruvate,
but has this additional
pieces on it.
And it turns out the next
step in the TCA cycle
is the exact
reaction that we saw
with pyruvate dehydrogenase.
It's alpha decarboxylation,
oxidative alpha
keto acid decarboxylation,
as follows.
So, we carry out.
This is a molecule
called succinyl-CoA.
And so, you'll see what happened
there is decarboxylated here,
this carbon, while oxidizing
this ketone to the acid
and adding -CoA.
That's a redox reaction.
So NAD, NADH, it turns out this
is exactly the same mechanism--
so I don't need
to draw it again--
that I just showed you for
pyruvate dehydrogenase.
So it needs all the
same cofactors--
TPP plus, lipoic acid, FAD.
And in fact, it even shares some
of the same enzyme complexes,
subunits, as pyruvate
dehydrogenase.
And so this is a reaction
that's catalyzed by alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase.
Like pyruvate dehydrogenase,
this is a complex,
and so it has a unique
E1, which makes sense.
Remember, E1 of
pyruvate dehydrogenase
was actually the subunit
that bound the pyruvate.
E1 of alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase is unique.
It binds alpha ketoglutarate
instead of pyruvate.
However, they share
the same E2 and E3s,
and so the E2s and
E3s would carry out
exactly the same reaction
and play the same part
in the mechanism of how you
do this alpha oxidative alpha
decarboxylation to turn
alpha ketoglutarate
into succinyl-CoA.
Now, remember in
pyruvate dehydrogenase,
once we got that
acetyl-CoA, we then
use this CoA group to drive
condensation with citrate.
Well, in this case,
what happens is
you don't want to combine
condensation here.
Instead, what is
going to happen is
you want to use this CoA
group to now generate ATP.
And so this is going to
couple release of the CoA
to generate an ATP equivalent.
It's actually GTP that's
generated by the TCA cycle.
And so, this is
going to generate
this molecule, succinate.
And the enzyme that does this
is called succinic bio-kinase.
So, let's go through over
here how this enzyme works.
So here's succinyl-CoA,
basically using favorable loss
of the CoA breaking the
thioester bond to generate
this acid anhydride.
We saw an acid anhydride
before in glycolysis.
Remember, we made
1-3-bisphosphoglycerate,
so that's a good
phosphate donor.
And then that can be used
to generate succinate,
and transferring that
phosphate to GDP to make GTP,
just like
1-3-bisphosphoglycerate,
was able to transfer
the phosphate
from the acid anhydride to
ADP to make ATP in glycolysis.
So, the next step is to
oxidize this carbon-carbon bond
in succinate.
So if we're going to oxidize
a carbon-carbon bond,
those electrons have
to go somewhere.
So there's our
carbon-carbon bond.
And so if we
generate hydride ion
just like we did in other
oxidation reactions,
but this hydride ion is
transferred not to NAD,
but instead to FAD, a
different electron carrier,
to generate if FADH2.
Now, I should point out
succinate, like citrate, is
a symmetrical molecule.
But at this point, nature
doesn't tell the difference.
Once it generates
succinate, this molecule
now gets scrambled.
And so everything
downstream of succinate,
you no longer know which
carbons came from acetyl-CoA.
This generates this
molecule called fumarate,
and this reaction is carried
out by an enzyme called
succinate dehydrogenase,
often abbreviated SDH
for succinate dehydrogenase.
Now, the next reaction
is, we're going
to add water across this
double bond of fumarate.
And that generates this
intermediate, malate.
This reaction is
carried out by an enzyme
called fumarate hydratase.
And it's simply adding
a water molecule
across that double bond.
Once we have malate,
if you look what's
the difference between
malate and oxaloacetate,
the difference is that in
oxaloacetate, this carbon
is a ketone.
Whereas in malate,
it's an alcohol.
And so if we want to turn
this carbon from the alcohol
into the ketone, that is, of
course, a oxidation reaction,
and so those electrons
have to go somewhere.
Don't need to draw
the mechanism again.
It's basically just
the hydride transfer
to oxidize this to an
alcohol, to the ketone.
That oxidation couples to a
reduction of NAD plus to NADH.
This is carried out by an enzyme
called malate dehydrogenase.
And doing this
completes the TCA cycle,
regenerating oxaloacetate,
that can then
recombine with
another acetyl-CoA
to go through another
round of the cycle.
You'll notice that going
through this cycle,
there's two CO2s lost.
One of them is lost here
at the isocitrate to alpha
ketoglutarate reaction.
So, this decarboxylation
from oxaloacetate
to alpha ketoglutarate.
That beta decarboxylation,
that's the first CO2.
The other one is lost here
at the alpha ketoglutarate.
The alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase step,
where you have this
alpha decarboxylation
to take alpha ketoglutarate
to succinyl-CoA
oxidative alpha decarboxylation.
Now, what's cool about
this, as you noticed,
we just discussed all the
reactions of the TCA cycle.
And I showed you, reminded
you, of some chemistry
that you've already
seen, but unless you
count the chemistry we showed
you earlier for how the PDH
and alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase
reactions work with E1, E2
and E3, with lipoic acid, FAD.
That was obviously
new for today.
But other than that,
everything else
was chemistry that
you've already seen.
And this really
points out the point
that I made earlier, that
metabolism is really variations
on relatively few reactions.
We've just repurposed some of
the same tricks, if you will,
that we're used in
glycolysis, and allowed
it to now do an entire different
pathway, the TCA cycle.
It also points out how Hans
Krebs was-- well, is still--
remarkable, able to figure
out from chemistry alone,
because there's actually quite
a bit of logic to the way
metabolism works.
Now, I want to say this again.
Note there were two carbons
that entered acetyl-CoA,
and two carbons that
were lost to CO2.
But if you look,
the green carbons
remain in the same places
until they get to succinate.
and so the two
carbons that enter
are not lost on the
first turn of the cycle.
It's actually two carbons
that came from oxaloacetate
that are converted to CO2
as that acetyl-CoA goes
through the cycle.
And so to oxidize the exact
carbons from acetyl-CoA to CO2
requires more than
one turn of the cycle.
You'll also notice that
the cycle is oxidation.
And so oxidation reactions,
of course, release energy.
We've talked about that.
And so it's favorable.
And the products, if you will,
are three NADH molecules.
You can say plus one more NADH
if we're going all the way
from glucose or from pyruvate.
Glucose derived pyruvate because
the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction also generates an
NADH to make that a acetyl-CoA.
One FADH2, as well
as one GTP molecule.
And so lots of
oxidation going on here.
We completely oxidized
two carbons to CO2,
so that's energy release.
But you notice you only get
one GTP from the molecule.
Now, this GTP, of
course-- that reaction,
the succinic
thiokinase reaction,
like the reactions
we saw on glycolysis,
is such that it can generate
GTP at a high DGP-GDP
ratio, or ATP-ADP ratio.
Remember, those are equivalent.
Those energy charge are similar,
and so that makes sense.
But most of the energy
released is actually
reducing NAD and FAD
to NADH and FADH2.
And of course, these need
to transfer their electrons
somewhere else, and
that's the role of oxygen.
Oxygen, remember, is a
very good electron donor,
and so it's the ultimate
transfer of those electrons
from these molecules to oxygen
that also provide energy
that the cell can use to do
work, but it does so, in a way,
by charging up different
ratios in the cell.
So the NAD-NADH or
the FADH2-FAD ratios.
And just like we talked about,
the ratio or the energy of ATP
is in the interconversion
between ATP and ADP.
It's the ratio that drives
the free energy change.
The same thing exists for an
NADH and NAD, FADH2 and FAD.
And so charging up these ratios
while passing through the TCA
cycle, and the ultimate
downstream transfer
of those electrons
to oxygen, really
is where most of the energy
is captured as carbon
is oxidized through
the TCA cycle.
And exactly how that works and
how it can be related to ATP
will be something that'll be
more explicit in the coming
lectures.
Now, I want to point out
apart from the oxidation,
there's actually lots of
intermediates made here.
And it turns out, a bunch
of these intermediates
are useful for
cells to make stuff.
So we talked about
gluconeogenesis.
Gluconeogenesis needs
electron balance.
We get NADH from the
TCA cycle, and so you
can think of gluconeogenesis
as an alternative
to fermentation to
dispose of electrons.
Well, you can use the
NADH from the TCA cycle
to run gluconeogenesis as well.
But beyond the cofactors,
the carbon itself.
So citrate, I've alluded
to now a few times,
is important as a
precursor to make fat.
We'll discuss that in
later lectures, too.
But other intermediates
in this pathway
are useful for various amino
acids and nucleic acids.
And so there's
lots of things that
can come from the
TCA cycle that cells
can find useful to do,
not just catabolism,
but also anabolic processes.
Now, the way the TCA
cycle works, though,
is that there's
actually an issue
if you want to use the
intermediates from the TCA
cycle to make stuff.
And so what is that issue?
Well, the TCA cycle functions
at a site as a cycle.
And so, if we're going to
take things in and out of it,
that has consequences
for how the cycle runs.
Now there's a couple
words for this
that I want to just
introduce to you.
The first one is cataplerosis
and the second one
is anaplerosis.
And so cataplerosis is
the act of removing stuff
from a metabolic cycle.
So, we're going
to remove citrate
from the cycle to make fat.
That's cataplerosis.
And anaplerosis is adding
stuff back to a metabolic cycle
so it can continue to function.
Viewing this is really evident
if you think of the TCA cycle
as a chicken and egg problem.
So, the very first
time acetyl-CoA
was generated, how
do you start the TCA
cycle in the first place?
You can't add it
to the TCA cycle
unless you have
oxaloacetate to combine
with the acetyl-CoA,
which can then
generate another oxaloacetate.
So where does the first
oxaloacetate come from?
Well, we already talked
about one reaction.
We talked about it in the
context of gluconeogenesis.
That can solve this problem.
And so we have pyruvate.
And so we talked
earlier today how
we can do oxidative
decarboxylation of pyruvate
to give acetyl-CoA.
But we talked to in
the gluconeogenesis
lecture how we can add a
CO2 pyruvate to generate
oxaloacetate.
So if I do those
two reactions, now I
have all the carbon I
need to generate a citrate
and start off the TCA cycle.
Now obviously, if
I do cataplerosis
and I remove that citrate
I made to make fat,
well, now I need
two pyruvate again
to generate the next citrate
if I'm using this pathway,
because every time I bring
an acetyl-CoA into the cycle,
I need an oxaloacetate
to combine it with.
And so if I remove something,
I have to add something back.
And so pyruvate to oxaloacetate,
the pyruvate carboxylase
reaction is an example of
an anaplerotic reaction.
Now what this means,
though, is that in order
to do an anaplerosis,
you have to be
able to generate
four-carbon oxaloacetate,
or a four-carbon molecule.
Now, pyruvate carboxylase,
pyruvate to oxaloacetate,
allows you to do that.
We can take a
three-carbon molecule
and generate four-carbon
oxaloacetate.
However, if we start from
a two-carbon molecule
like acetate or acetyl-CoA
that enters the cycle,
it's actually not so simple to
take that two-carbon molecule
and turn it into
four-carbon oxaloacetate.
And in fact, humans
lack any enzymes
that allow them to
take a two-carbon unit,
to take acetate or
acetyl-CoA, and turn it
into anything that's
longer than net-- turn
it into anything that's
longer than two carbons.
And this has
important implications
for human physiology,
because what it says
is that we can't make
glucose from anything
that starts with something
less than three carbons long.
So if you drink alcohol and
you metabolize that alcohol
to acetate, it turns
out you take fat
and you break down fat
also to acetyl-CoA,
to acetate two carbons long.
There is no way to turn
those molecules into glucose,
because you cannot generate
the oxaloacetate to do
the anaplerosis that's
necessary to get it there.
What this means is
that our body can only
store calories that come
from two carbon units,
fat or alcohol, as fat.
We can never turn them back
into glucose or make glycogen.
And this is very relevant
for those of you that
go to medical
school, because it's
relevant to our physiology.
And that is, when
our bodies exhaust
all of our stores of
glucose, what happens?
Our liver can no longer
do gluconeogenesis.
And so what happens?
Now it has to switch over
to doing something else.
It has to work with
two carbon units.
And ultimately, this is
ketone metabolism, which we'll
talk about in a few lectures.
It also said that the body--
that this is also the basis
of a very old adage that's
out there that some of
you may have heard--
that you need to have
some other fuel if you're
going to burn fat.
The basis for that is that
fat is turned into two carbon
units, acetyl-CoA units.
And so if you're going to
take those acetyl-CoA units
and ultimately burn them
away, turn them into CO2,
you need a source
of oxaloacetate,
or your TCA cycle won't work.
And you don't need a lot of
something, but it is true.
You can't start just with
acetyl-CoA as a human and turn
it into CO2, so you need some--
at least a little
bit of oxaloacetate
to get your TCA cycle started.
Now, that's a problem that we as
humans and other mammals face,
but it turns out there's
lots of microbes out there
that grow just fine on
acetate or on alcohol,
even if it's only carbon source.
And so those organisms
must have some way
to build stuff from
two carbon units.
That is a way to use two carbon
units and do an anaplerosis.
And it turns out the way
they do this is via something
called the glyoxylate cycle.
And so the glyoxylate cycle
is an alternative version
of the TCA cycle that
effectively uses two enzymes
that we lack as mammals.
And so I'll quickly
tell you about it here.
So, this is isocitrate
from the TCA cycle.
And some microbes have an
enzyme called isocitrate lyase.
And what isocitrate lyase does
is basically splits citrate
in half, such that the top
portion of the molecule
is another TCA cycle
intermediate, succinate.
And the bottom
portion of a molecule
is this two carbon
aldehyde called glyoxylate.
Glyoxylate can react with
acetyl-CoA by another enzyme
that we lack as humans
called malate synthase.
And I don't have time to
show the mechanism again,
but malate synthase basically
adds the two carbons
from acetyl-CoA to the
aldehyde, the carbonyl,
the aldehyde carbonyl of
glyoxylate in a reaction that
is, for all intents and
purposes, exactly what happens
in citrate synthase.
That will generate this
molecule, which is malate, also
in the TCA cycle.
And so having these two extra
reactions, isocitrate lyase
and malate synthase,
gives microbes
the ability to have
acetyl-CoA be anaplerotic.
And so how does that work?
Well, that's because if we start
with one oxaloacetate, four
carbons, and acetyl-CoA, two
carbons, can run the TCA cycle
and make citrate, six carbons.
Turn that citrate
into isocitrate.
Use isocitrate lyase to generate
glyoxylate, two carbons.
Plus succinate.
That succinate can run through
succinate dehydrogenase
to generate malate,
which you can
go through malate dehydrogenase
to generate oxaloacetate.
This glyoxylate can start
with a second acetyl-CoA.
Two carbons come
together, generate malate.
That generates a
second malate molecule,
which can then exit the cycle
as malate or oxaloacetate
or whatever you want.
And so basically, it allows
two acetyl-CoAs to net
generate an oxaloacetate,
and so net generates a way
to do an anaplerosis
from two carbon units
by having this malate
synthase reaction
and this isocitrate
lyase reaction
and run this alternative
version of the TCA cycle,
called the glyoxylate cycle.
And it's a nice way how life--
again, no new chemistry here,
just variations on what
we've already shown--
repurposed the
similar chemistries
that it's already using
as a way to live off
of carbon sources that contain
only two carbons, like ethanol
or acetate.
So in closing today,
the last thing
I want to talk
about, very briefly,
is how the TCA
cycle is regulated.
And we don't need to
spend a ton of time
on this, because it really
follows principles that
make sense, particularly when
we think about things that we've
already talk about.
And so, regulation of the TCA
cycles is of course important,
and it's really a critical hub,
both for anabolic and catabolic
pathways.
So, you needed to get energy
to fully oxidize carbon,
but it's also a useful
place to get stuff.
And before I talk
about regulation,
I just want to point out that
many of the enzymes in the TCA
cycle, even though we talk
about it in the mitochondria
and we're about to talk
about regulation in terms
of catabolism--
that is oxidation,
ways to release energy--
many of these enzymes are
also in other locations
in the cell, because there's
functions for them in making
stuff that is very different
than what goes on in the TCA
cycle.
And the regulation that
I'll tell you about,
and that comes up on
MCAT exams and stuff
like that, usually
talks about this pathway
as a catabolic pathway, as a
way to make CO2, to make ATP.
However, recognize
that there's also
variations on this pathway that
can use in anabolic things,
making stuff.
And that regulation is something
that really is not necessarily
what we're going
to talk about here
and is a little bit
less well-understood.
But at least the
regulation, in terms
of catabolism, if we put it in
context of glucose metabolism--
so here's glycolysis, turning
glucose into pyruvate.
And then that
pyruvate can operate
through the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction
to generate acetyl-CoA.
That acetyl-CoA can
combine with oxaloacetate
to generate citrate.
That citrate, of course,
can be used to generate fat,
as we've talked about.
That can go to isocitrate.
Isocitrate to alpha
ketoglutarate.
That's catalyzed by
isocitrate dehydrogenase,
which I will abbreviate IDH.
Alpha ketoglutarate
to succinate.
More correctly, to succinyl-CoA
by alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase, Alpha KGDH.
And then this back
to oxaloacetate.
And so the main enzymes
that are typically
discussed as being regulated
are alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase,
isocitrate dehydrogenase,
and pyruvate dehydrogenase.
I also drew glycolysis.
And I'll just write over
here, gluconeogenesis up here,
because we can now see
more fully how this plays
in with citrate acting
as a positive regulator
with gluconeogenesis and
an inhibitor of glycolysis.
Again, we're full in citrate,
stop running glycolysis,
start running gluconeogenesis.
Now, the other regulation.
If you have a lot of
acetyl-CoA, stop making it
from pyruvate. acetyl-CoA is
a negative regulator of PDH.
This is carbon oxidation.
Releases a lot of energy,
generates a lot of ATP,
generates a lot of NADH.
If you have lots
of those things,
no reason to keep
sending carbon into
acetyl-CoA to go
into the TCA cycle.
Ultimately, we have to send
those electrons somewhere.
So if there's
nowhere to put them,
low oxygen also inhibits
pyruvate dehydrogenase.
And of course, if you need
more energy, if ADP is high,
that activates
pyruvate dehydrogenase.
So at least in terms of glucose,
complete glucose oxidation,
a lot of regulation happens
at pyruvate dehydrogenase.
And a lot of it
really makes sense.
High levels of ATP,
high levels of NADH,
also inhibit isocitrate
dehydrogenase and alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase.
Makes sense.
Succinol-CoA high, inhibit alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase.
High levels of ADP, need
to release more energy,
activate alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase.
Again, these are the feedbacks
that people talk about
on board exams.
Good to know, but you can
almost guess what they
would be from first principles.
Because remember,
this is a pathway
that releases a lot of energy.
High energy high
ATP, high NADH--
don't run the cycle, don't
enter carbon in the cycle.
Low energy, high ADP,
put carbon in the cycle,
run the cycle faster.
Makes sense.
Also makes sense of the
reciprocal regulation
of glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis.
Great.
Next time, we will
talk more about
how we can oxidize fatty acids,
fat, by accessing acetyl-CoA
and entering it into the cycle.
Thanks.